Last week
the president's chief of staff told CNN,
United States is no longer trying
to contain the Corona virus.
And instead they're gonna be focusing
on therapeutics and an eventual vaccine.
This is great news for our newest sponsor
which has developed a new COVID vaccine,
exclusively for men.
Check out their ad.
[Narrator] Being a dude just got Better.
BroBox,
the number one online supplier
of subscription-based
hair loss treatments,
dong stiffeners
and nut grooming products
is about to set your lungs
to a beast mode.
With our new COVID Vaccine for Men.
It's the first COVID
vaccine made exclusively
for bros like you.
And it's FDA approved.
Our BroBox subscribers
are already seeing incredible results.
I love that my BroBox COVID vaccine,
is made just for guys like me,
who live it all on the court.
swish.
(breathes heavily)
Thanks to the BroBox COVID vaccine.
My lungs have a definition
of vascularity
that I've always wanted to achieve.
Sorry about the sweat.
I've been sweating nonstop
for almost three weeks now.
with little to no physical activity.
BroBox says
that's probably the vaccine working.
I'm so thirsty.(chuckles)
[Narrator] We can tell you
about all the dangerous side effects
and there are a shit ton.
But wouldn't you rather just
watch the snowboarding video?
Nice.
So pump up your BroBox
online subscription
with our new COVID Vaccine for Men.
And if you have any complaints
just remember,
we don't have offices.
Technically,
we're not even a company.
BroBox.
We're just an attractive typeface.